got frank grillo in the house and Frank
Frank looks me he comes out and we're
I'm gonna pick him up and he goes like
this he goes [ __ ] and I go what what's
wrong I thought said indrani's and he
had a sunglasses on he's looking in the
garage and his garage door like it's a
mirror and he goes I look like I'm a guy
who models sunglasses tight t-shirts and
torn jeans let's get out of here
let's go man no really Frank I'm 43
really really good though thank you
really what I was saying to myself
that's another language that covers up
the real language is I look in the
mirror and go I hate your guts I want to
smash your head in that round so it you
know another party sir it's a feathered
pillow
I don't hurt mice anyway in a way like
your your career has never been better
oh not we're a lot better that's not
true Frank that's fine it is what it is
I've only known Frank since he's been
killing about four years now he's
killing ever since I've known so I don't
know the other Freddie was always like
six now years seven years now he's
producing movies too so it's a big it's
a whole different stratosphere yeah
graduate at OU's now I did got more
attached it's midlife crisis was that
right here no he got it in time I got
him in there on the boom in Thailand no
no I got these two in Thailand this one
in Thailand before the show before way
before and these were in China the show
being fight was go fight world yeah it's
on Netflix now it's streaming and it's
surprisingly because I'm used to things
falling into [ __ ] people have responded
very very positive it's good you know me
I'm a hater when it comes to fight stuff
and ITEX I was in Utah and I was my
brother and I were watching Netflix I
was a guy I gotta check out [ __ ]
fight world man Frank's on it I usually
stay away from fight stuff yeah and it
was damn good man it's so good
well yeah what's his name who wrote and
directed and I mean who basically
directed and edited well he he Patrick
Pat McKinley who is a very famous alias
editor and then came to work on Kingdom
the TV show that we did and then he
directed the last couple of episodes
which I thought whether two of the best
episode the Israeli Israel when you went
to Israel yep
and Senegal no no he directly West
episodes a king answer and so I get we
came to Pat and I said I want you to
direct this I don't know what it's gonna
be but here's the premise and we had an
outline and we found storylines we had
great producers who found storylines and
then we'd follow each storyline and and
then one would always surface as being
the a storyline like any documentary
there's no it something's gonna
something's gonna happen you know and
you kind of like let it dictate what it
wants to be you don't try to force the
narrative right and it's honest you know
and I kind of take a step
unlike Bourdain which is kind of the
genesis of the idea I step back I I
don't want to take the spotlight away
from these people who you know the
reason why I'm there is because I have
such respect for him and they kind of
tell their own stories so it turned out
I'm telling you it's really really good
I appreciate that I wish I could say I
was responsible for how it came out
because it was but he came out better
than what my idea was yeah but your
ideas what led doesn't it led to your
your passion for yeah that's why this
thing works it is my good if they would
have sent some [ __ ] who doesn't know
fighting it wouldn't work yeah I have
such an incredible deep deep-rooted
respect for people who fight I really do
it in any capacity so that yeah that
that trailer chin it is so damn good way
it's shot fighting for what you believe
in you look like you got stung by all
the bees that instinct to fight to
survive to protect
but this is any show about fighting
this is a show about people who fight
I'm Frank Grillo I'm an actor and a
lifelong fight enthusiast this is like
folklore to me I can't say how much
respect I have to you know nominate my
dragon the Vedanta Itamar option our
house is supposed to defend the honor
pride and dignity of this community
represents freedom appreciation for what
these real professionals
we used martial arts as a platform for
bringing different minority groups
together these kids found each other for
this I think that fighting everything
becomes so clear everybody bleeds the
same everybody sweats the same everyone
who fights has to have a reason why and
I think that in the end most reasons are
at the same
and I'll say this is it's not a show
about yes obviously Fighting's the
narrative there it's a show about people
oh yeah yeah it's more about people and
I always like what do UFC whenever I
have issues with fighters and I can
market it and stuff like that or getting
the proper recognition they should it's
because I know their stories right like
if you guys would just tell their story
like there's a million why did you that
oh my gosh there's a million fighters
out there and everyone's fighting for
the same reason glory and sacrifice and
they come from nothing and there's all
that right everyone stories that right
but there's too many to choose from
but if you can relate to one person's
story where and you get the inside that
they're fighting for their son or right
there they're come from this background
it goes so much further I know that's
that's what and that's what you do here
with these guys every every analyst and
I was in pretty I mean oppressive
oppressive poverty it's you know Seneca
there's parts of Senegal though it's an
AA you're sickening how poor they are
that's where real fighting comes from
yeah and and and and tippy-toe and
Mexico and they're all smiling some
reason well having a good time yeah but
but you know in Thailand you know I was
in the jungles of Thailand I mean these
kids were eating a bowl of rice a day
and they were training seven hours and
how old were those kids oh they were
like 12 13 14 years old that kid with
the black and blue face was 14 years old
he fought two weeks earlier and he still
had that kind of damage you know why
they don't have refrigeration you know
what that means
they don't have ice oh so I went to give
him ice and he was like because the
others were looking at him everybody's
looking at him I was I never thought of
that yeah they don't have ice in of ice
so there's the inflammation and they
those kids have hundreds of fights all
the time yeah oh yeah the kid the other
kid who I was following who was 16 I
could get 158 fights no the Thai kid
yeah that's yeah Frank got my problem
would be is like one time I did this
this tour and a six sick kids children
hospital and I wondered like I'm like do
Bob I'll buy him with everyone right
right I felt like I was like dude all me
what toys does he thought yeah yeah did
you feel when you're within like
you talk about white guys to LA like
give you know kids when you have kids
the age of these very and and but you
know what
and it's an it's a very American thing
to bond I want to fix it yeah you know
but but sometimes it causes more
problems than it you think it's to kind
of start to give because then they're
gonna give the equipment to somebody and
not everybody's gonna get it and it
creates a problem internally for them
[ __ ] up the ecosystem Idul East right
warrants right like they have a
structure and then we come and go yeah
we do it like this well I'm like whoa
we're doing now one example one example
of that that an old example was my my my
aunt and uncle spent a lot of time in
Africa and my uncle's a botanist and so
he spent a great deal of time creating
crops that were more nutritious right
and figuring out ways to till the soil
and get more inste blah blah but also my
aunt was part of a project that was
built digging wells so that people the
women didn't have to go down to the
river and go walk the two miles was but
also you know crocodiles all kinds of
issues so they said let's take wells
what was very interesting is that when
they dug the wells and they had these
Western companies coming in and do the
high-tech wells and everybody didn't
know nobody had to go down to the river
anymore what they didn't foresee was
that went on the walk and at the river
was where the women bonded gossip has
their social to had their social Terror
women and it was part of the fabric of
that society and that destroyed the
fabric and completely of no release
right and it through so so who could
have a sack you late that yeah we had in
the Amazon where we did discover trot
groups of people who were still living
like there were 2,000 years yeah and
let's get them Levi's and let's get them
in J let's inject my balls in it yeah
yeah in 30 years they had cancer you
know they were overweight yeah you know
I mean certainly civilization brings
with it its own set of problems there's
no question yeah exactly
there's a great stat that's been pretty
sussed out by historians and and when
when a white man was went to a Native
American tribe before 1860 I think when
when whiten wood was sort of like they'd
be wounded or they'd be captured where
it was or if the kids would be adopted
by Joe but certainly when a white man
went to live with Native Americans they
never went back to white society like
that it was very very calm yeah they
stayed with that tribe right they were
like wait a minute
this is a one way to living because days
baby the Native Americans had been
living that way forever like the Nez
Perce and stuff one of the stories is
that they had so many so dipped so many
different kinds of food they jerked meat
they had different kind of so they just
understood their land so when people
would go they were like first of all
everybody everybody looks super healthy
they are all there emotionally to the
white girls let's show the white devil
that's what you saw a lot of Native
Americans who were who kind of brought
into Christian society taught the Bible
taught schooling a lot of them after
that as soon as they could went right
back to their I'm sure you made some
connections with all the guys in the
same the fighters all uh you're like
you're a friendly dude yeah about people
and you know what I would do in every
gym is I would go there like a day early
and I'd go in I'd get up and you know I
had guys with me so I'd either we'd
either work the mitts and stuff or I'd
start start working the bag and jumping
rope I wouldn't say anything to anybody
and they would watch and then I would I
would slowly kind of migrate towards
them and start talking to him and then I
was just just just like you do in every
gym Yeah right and I'll say this about
Frank I know it sounds like I'm sucking
you off right now but a box and burn
Frank would be in there more more often
than not more than me
usually he'd be in there longer and
working out harder than me and that's
when I was a fighter but I'd bet
everyone respected you
yeah I have my even I was like [ __ ]
yours Frank and then you know is Frank
doing this thing yeah like [ __ ] like a
Frank oh yeah yeah just because I
believe I have zero talent in anything
so the but the only thing I
do is yeah work harder copy
yeah it's comfortable but I think that
again that's why I think this show works
cuz if you would have sent name anyone
who doesn't know the fight game not read
never really trained hasn't been through
kind of the harsh conditions of gyms
even if they're in LA right gyms aren't
that exactly friendly right even box and
more especially when I was fighting as
more of a fight gym its upright friendly
is right or you know a wildcards not the
friendliest black house is not a fighter
you will take in guys there's high state
yeah they're not trying to have some
Hollywood guy in there right the
limelight so ruined Frank come there and
do work like I'll [ __ ] man in he's one
of us yeah wouldn't work if they would
have sent some you name anybody you want
you're right if they were saying just
some regular Joe you're right these
fighters Mike dude what the road of like
god I can't believe you in the face man
are you okay like no I and I got to tell
you they were even some you know when I
went to like Senegal and these are these
guys are bigger than you I swear they're
ginormous human beings and and I'm
watching them and and you know that
Lamba is is bare-knuckle boxing and sand
and to Greco wrestling and high-level
grec like high-level takedowns like
sounds like MMA it does it's really
version of it kind of words and it would
go on for an hour
going from do you watch that up step
that one there's so big dude there a lot
of them are Muslim but there's Sufi a
lot of them are Sufi Muslim which is
very mystical and yeah I mean they are
just look at the size are they they're
they getting paid for this right um the
big guys get paid and they're there they
are the rock stars of western Africa
really the guys locked lock do guerre
and Moodle oh the two champions who
fought when I was there they are that
like they are
Mick Jagger Elvis Presley Michael Jordan
wrapped up oh yeah yeah yeah and did
they but and their nutrition I'm
assuming is not great no in fact the the
motor low who was who fought yeah these
guys by the way they don't lift weights
the way you think they watchin say Moses
genetics Jannetty and yes rice and fish
right didn't you tell me they live on
the ocean right rice fish but it's not
like they're like you know the guys here
eating
two hours away modern their micros in
micro you know listen they're more
everything to them is inshallah
right by God on the other gods inshallah
meaning only guide sing God's in God's
hands
yeah right they are a beautiful human
being you have to see how good they are
they grow up doing this sport so these
kids are amazing look at this guy I'm
surprised no one's ever gone over the
recruited I in the bottom - Harding -
but there are problems with getting them
over here again they are they are the
most peaceful tolerant people in fact
Obama went there and said the world
could learn from Senegal because they
are the most tolerant human beings they
voted for a Catholic president and it's
poverty over there oh my gosh terrible
oh by the way he was there and they show
it on fight world he was there right and
they were about to have the fight the
next day and at the soccer stadium yeah
there's a riot that there's a broader
stadium and it collapsed and eight
people were killed including a night
before the fight yeah so they cancel the
fight but they all cancel a fight and
they were even the fighters everybody
was really reverential right wasn't it
really quiet yes at prayers they said
prayers and then the next day we called
the what we called a meeting with the
the the president of this this the
league that they and the Sports Minister
and the Minister of the Interior to see
what we could do to raise awareness to
get this stadium you know what they said
it's inshallah God opposes God disposes
Jesus man yeah and that's when the state
wanted to what and so was kind of like
releases a lot of anxiety though yeah if
you really are that connected to a
higher being a higher power because I
was stressed out of my mind like I would
be to a great little girl died and I was
like I was standing in the stadium I was
right there makes you feel sick yeah I
mean there it was it collapsed than they
were they were all they were all killed
it was really a horrific scene that's
the one thing that I think that you you
get when you travel especially in the
developing world is that people put so
much faith into fate and into God do
they value life the same way Americans
do very much so the thing that people
don't realize is that in in so so when
Iraq I don't know if remember but in
Iraq war when Isis was coming in and in
the Yazidi so the Azizi are
they're their own sort of tribe in Iraq
bring up the yzi D and the women were
always famed for their beauty in fact in
Iraq they were it was very common to see
as eating women who are blond-haired
blue-eyed believe it or not there there
and there was a there were a lot of like
Miss ROM so of course these [ __ ] Isis
[ __ ] go let's go get those girls
rape them let's see we owe their not
real Muslims so let's go and they what
they did is they sold them to slavery
what you have to realize about those
women is in those communities is that
they were [ __ ] they are very close
they've been in those enclaves for
thousands of years those villages are
tight you know everybody yeah so all of
these guys come and take all your women
and kill you so so the when you when you
talk about tolerating a life or loving
life more than you can imagine more than
you can imagine and in and in in Senegal
from my experience living overseas
closer than a lot of families here like
to see that that's a t-girl you see the
blue eyes and the blond hair that's
that's what they look like and so I mean
look at that that's it that's it that's
it she's a Zaraki she goes back
beautiful kids how's ins of years and
that's the children those the the women
that they were taking those children
they were they were selling his slaves
so you can't imagine how horrible was
but the point is is that those villages
and those people are so tight and one of
the things that politicians in the
United States said when they would see
they go to India and they say look I
think Mother Teresa said this remember
you know mother Trey says she worked she
she was little and she was a Hungarian
nun she was a Hungarian nun who ran all
the charities in India and she said I've
never seen poverty so we yes India has
incredible poverty but I've never seen
poverty like having the United States
and said what are you talking about said
spiritual poverty right no one is
connected said when you see a family in
India they're on the street but they're
all together I'm guilty I'm guilty of it
I mean so what happens is in America and
Western society you're so busy working
on work on success that's what we value
right that's what we value and I get the
house get the cars you know get the
right friend like get your so-and-so you
during that time when you're not
succeeding you're connected to something
because you need something and then we
get and we tend to and I've done it
get get away from some spiritual
connection yes and then you get yourself
into trouble
you get yourself until you need it into
uni which I yeah yeah so that's again
you got to be but all of these places
that I went to they were all very
spiders or spiritual guys but but yeah
you know from Myanmar to Thailand to
Africa tippy-toe Mexico you know which
is the worst the most dangerous part of
Mexico cities where all the drug cartel
yeah that's what I want to ask you Frank
like two-part question or a were you
ever worried about your safety B how do
you decide what places to go to let's
start with were you ever worried a
couple times I was worried worried you
know and I was warned so I made me a
little more anxious and before you say
this when you talk about that place in
Mexico the cartels of we have a mutual
friend
the he's the agent for the the the
narcos team oh yeah that Flay the show
my guy who scouts the location yeah was
in that area yeah murdered yeah he's
girders kill they said while it because
he didn't they didn't know who was dead
fit in there okay they just shot him so
if you watching to go if you watch
Mexico the episode you just I'm with I'm
with a little old guy at way after we
went to horror there is Jim I'm with a
little Mexican guy who is the leader of
the most dangerous drug cartel in Tepito
he became my guardian to him and his son
right and and wherever I went in Tepito
he said right now wherever you are
in Tepito there are four hundred eyes on
you right now with guns everything is
run by them right now 99 percent of the
people in Tepito are beautiful
hard-working tacos amazing human beings
friendly and gracious and they were
couldn't be more loving inviting but he
said if I step away from you you're in
trouble the whole crew is in trouble and
we were there we felt it really so I had
30 guys with me at any time so I had to
have you know there were a lot of people
looking out for us and you know what you
know what I don't care if they're if
they're on the wrong side of the law or
everybody
spec's fighters correct fighting they
just do whoever it is it's it's an 8 in
men it's a respect men who battle fight
hmm and so if you're there to show the
world what's good about Tepito
and what's good about Mexican boxing and
to and to kind of brag about the
resident trainer from Tepito yeah it
makes them look it makes them feel good
I had a similar story Frey I was when I
was getting ready to fight Nogueira and
Brazil I was out there months before to
do PR and they flew me Forrest Griffin
who was fighting Silva so there's the
two Americans and someone drove by I
forget how blue in the favela out there
which yes that's where I was just
thought I mean the hood of the hood yeah
and there's guys with huge ak-47s and
like this is grand operated by the the
gangs of Garcia like you gotta beat
watch your P's and Q's here man I fir
doing something there and I went and I
saw you were handing out weren't your
hand hold on so I was in there and it
was just like kids are doing jiu-jitsu
on dirt and their backs are all [ __ ]
up and their bare foot doing high kicks
and I just like what the [ __ ] and
they're not eating I felt so bad for him
I said I got to do something man and got
the American where it's like no you
don't you were not going back in here
man he was like I'm telling you be in
trouble
and then the Brazilian who was with us
goes no everyone in this favela respects
Brennan because he's a fighter right and
he's coming to our land to fight our
legend he's gonna highlight what we do
right because he he he can do no wrong
here no one's gonna hurt him right then
he goes put the crew not so much right
they don't know you guys right Brendan's
gonna be good so they had to bring all
Brazilian crew with me right and we went
in there and delivered gloves and shin
pads yeah but but I didn't feel even
when went in there like you feel younger
the roughest of the rough in Brazil no I
felt love I felt like yeah there was a
sixth episode it was Brazil I was in Rio
de Janeiro but what happened was we
could not the episode a couple of things
happen we're just it did we couldn't get
it out in time right so I spent all my
time in the favelas plus I was with
Hobson Gracie
right I was with hooker Gracie I was
with what's-his-name from
leave it leave a who beat who fought
Gregson on the sand in 1980
oh Jesus olds oh he's amazing
I wrestled with him on the beach where
he fought Hickson who did yeah yeah
remember that and who else was I I was
which and then I was with Jose Aldo and
a day's team I was with that whole team
and I trained there for a few days
so my point being I was in the favelas
and we followed one of the story lines
with a gym in the favelas that trained
all the kids for free to take to teach
them all Jitsu and I wound up spending a
couple days there and having lunch there
and dinner there with these guys and it
was the same thing they couldn't get
enough of me because hey I love
jiu-jitsu and and I could I you know
they they knew who I was meeting with
right and I was giving back to them a
sense of ownership of something so here
they were in the favelas and we were
there to kind of to kind of talk them up
to highlight it and that's all they have
a lot of people don't realize it Frank
Frank was training with Hickson Gracie
for Europe hit some grace in a purple
belt long time you train with him why
don't you walk in well Halloween 90 he
was the trailer garage before anybody in
the house aids in his garage in his
garage yeah used to use what with his
kids everything else blew those babies
yeah they just to play paintball rone
and all that man yeah Dan that's nuts
man
you go to Aarthi what was the what was
the place because for me the most moving
episode in a lot of ways and they were
all kind of really emotionally moving to
me but the Israel was pretty amazing
because they fight there's a philosophy
there yeah now you were around these
sort of Special Forces guys but the way
they articulated what they did and the
philosophy behind it was almost the
philosophy of their entire country and
the existence yeah so it was pretty
heavy and it was a bit it was a bit of a
departure from the other shows in the
sense that it wasn't you know it wasn't
us it wasn't a fight culture based on
sport it was a fight culture based on
survival yeah you know be and I learned
a lot about you know I think I was
fairly ignorant when when thinking about
what Israel is you know surrounded by 25
hostile nations everyone's oyster and
what these people you know how they
managed to live pretty
normal cosmopolitan existences
especially in Tel Aviv or you know and
then always have your head on a swivel
and and people are surround you who
don't want you to exist or your children
and they're doing then they're dealing
with it yeah and then you know look I'm
I didn't get pull it on to get political
about it I don't know enough about
Israel and Palestine and I'm I'm an
Italian guy from New York so it's it's
it's there you're not Italian from me a
little bit and in that video that guy
has you kicking him I was in the
beginning I was just like tapping
because I have my shoes on inside I feel
weird it was weird right that's why I
kept saying kick me kick yeah the other
shows not like you that money I almost
felt like I don't know
yeah lay offs like ah this guy's awkward
he's he get out of there friend anyway
yeah he was intense
well he looks like a guy who's who's
almost always ready to kill you he is
there's a different thing where he's
yeah it was more than a punch somebody
he goes he draws him ass back back back
and you know he's listen this he's like
he's like a SEAL Team six guy yeah he's
real right zone two in the tunnels of
the Gaza Strip this guy fights
hand-to-hand he's he's he was a world
champion I mean there's so many world
champion kung fu guy muy Thai like live
didn't he let's see violence was that
language when I tell you the level of
speed in a [ __ ] ibbity that was when
he grabs the gun really oh it's you know
jiu-jitsu is kind of like free-flowing
hello man like it really is he said when
I got hit Frank hold the gun on him
first he does the thing and he goes the
gun sterilize okay here and Frank hasn't
got any cuz now if you put the gun give
me your money and Franco's give me your
money and he goes why what happened what
do we want and he's moving forward and
so he was I'm always closing the digital
give you whatever here and he goes to
reach for his and Frank's eyes go down
to his hands again yeah and he grabs a
gun and he goes now you cannot you see
it did you can there's nothing there's
nothing to do here because no matter
what you can do I have and he slid he
pushed the slide back and had his finger
on the trigger so this he disengaged
weapon like that hey there now so fast
now he hadn't roll that one bang bang
bang his shot Frank I was like oh Jesus
Christ but literally he goes what what
happened
like he's an actor does this show a clip
up in here on Jimmy we gotta see that
we've got to see that Israel thing
because it's [ __ ] I myself in Jimmy I
cannot just play this and see if it's on
there it was so great look at Frank look
at the cutie pie want to tell you
something that that has the only other
time that's happened on the show was
when Carol Burnett was here I thought
well you could still punch me I would
not want to do that and well tell us
about your new show because I did see it
and it's did you see they showed you the
trail yes that's how I look like imagery
interests you are don't I look like a
guy's been a good man in a bar for a
while yeah and I traveled around the
world doing films and stuff and
everywhere I went I would go to a gym
let's watch another guy interview yeah
yeah do they show a clip of that oh
there's the picture he's the guy who
teaches the guys Krav Maga he is the
most famous guy I know right but he is
the master and you do see certain guys
who were just thick he's a killer he's a
killer
yeah well that's he wants to fight
McGregor with a gun sense for the gun
[Laughter]
yeah it's a lot of those guys have
moustaches so how'd you decide on where
to go Frank so I told the producers I
said look let's find places with sports
right now that include either grappling
you know muy Thai boxing what are the
countries and let's see if we have ins
and I got to tell you because of what
little celebrity I have from the Marvel
movies in the whatever movies and stuff
it was kind of an it was it was a smooth
in no one resisted no one resisted
because they you know they saw me as
like an action guy and he's you know
legitimate and so you did start on the
biggest movie China's put out oh yeah
the big Chinese movie - so utterly a
wolf for
- yeah but did you do anything in China
nope no no no but we went to we went to
places that I fell you know look we got
booked how to say yeah come to my gym
and you know so that when we got rid we
got nacho Beristain to say come to my
gym you know Julio Cesar Chavez said
come and will interview me at the
stadium where he beat Greg Howe again
and a cheeky Chiquita Gonzales and I was
with all of the top athletes in each of
those countries so it was it was it
happened I have to tell you most things
in my life there's such it's so hard to
do like I always have like conflict this
show and maybe that's why it came out
the way did it was so kind of it never
resisted it really didn't and and and
and then I forgot about it because it
was such a cool experience how long ago
did you shoot it a year ago yeah so
someone like Julio Cesar Chavez is he is
he just everywhere he walks he's still a
[ __ ] rock star in Mexico no dude
yeah he's a rock star everywhere
everywhere even here I did a show with
him at ESPN and yeah I mean he's between
takes on the set people are coming up
gimpy yeah he won 82 fights before the
greatest Mexican boxer in somewhere it's
never right you know arguably one of the
greatest by you know how boxers a
Mexican white by a hundred you know
Floyd talks about his 50 wins this guy
no he doesn't strike me as being punchy
either he's not at all and he's shredded
he's in shape to this shape and then his
son Chavez Jr he has an issue because
you not can be your dad you know
don't grow up with him as your father
having all the money in the world but he
was [ __ ] man he's won a lot of fight
he's good but but he's a my gym just not
he's not that upper echelon type of dude
but not he's [ __ ] good he is good in
sports isn't in question he really he
just doesn't come out of the you know
when you when you listen to his father
speak like when I was interviewing he
came out of poverty he came out of
nothing he was fighting for his family
that's why he's great
that's why he's great jr. he's not they
said let me fight Canelo like I'm like
Bucky looks good they're talking about
how in shape he is Freddie Roach was
like I'm not work
this guy's too undisciplined he's too
into drugs he's like just enjoys to come
out so you know he just think of
fortunes and then I was like [ __ ] he's
in shape he does have skill he killed
which he does and he's big I thought he
is great you're good he's identity he's
big for his weight Canella went scuse me
I'm the real Mexican boxer here yeah and
beat the [ __ ] out of him I know and
because Canelo comes from poverty know
that I didn't know canal came from now
and he's like one of eight ya know and
he was like his work ethic so I would do
workouts on Saturday mornings with
Justin and him with with junior either
at UCLA or at the gym and you know I'm
twice as old as he is and I don't know
if he noticed but I'm not a professional
athlete and he I could I could I didn't
hang with him I know he couldn't keep up
with we would do circuit training
we couldn't he can't know you are a
beast so I'll give you that but a guy
getting ready to fight Cannella probably
should be able to be frank grillo yeah I
would think so but I mean but again 117
like come on no I thought yeah that's
bad news and it's not that he can't it's
that he didn't want to he didn't care
yeah it's tough man can you blame him
but he decided to go down that path like
he's good he's better than people think
I'm off a guy's skill said he's better
that he's tougher they should be another
one great you know I mean that's like
you didn't go visit Malibu searching for
badass fighters there's a reason before
no fighters to the so awesome Malibu all
the guys think they're by the way Frank
Frank
if you hang with Frank in LA the first
thing he does we're at the up Soho house
in Malibu were in Hollywood and he just
I swear to god this is what he does
he just sits there he's like then you
need to see him like this you know go
[ __ ] everybody's a [ __ ] you know I
can't stand this place well you here's
the deal so I get to travel to all these
places and it's a gift it's a blessing
and I get to meet all these amazingly
tough beautiful warriors right I mean
badasses and they're poor and they're
badasses and they're studs right and
they're sweet and humble and they are
loving and they don't don't want to
intimidate anybody there we go
you know
ego and then I go to the solo house
which I love I love the solo house in
Malibu it's my kind of sure I'm away
from here I like you and I see them I
see dudes walking with you know with a
false bravado yeah sweater around they
just on ain't ignorant as blessed they
just don't know they just say don't I
say this all the time and I'm not a
tough guy but let me tell you something
somebody might be Vito so much because
you are the height that somebody cuts
cut somebody cuts off Brendan chop right
yeah and the guy says you know what I'm
a badass in Malibu he says get out pow
you guys never been punched in the face
and I've been taken down he doesn't know
what it feels like to have a figure for
around his man waist I've been with
Brendan when guys have tried to do that
and then in effect you have you just
don't have a clue but I think it's tough
to for actors especially because if you
play a tough guy or you know you fall
into that because you got to train for
the part and then you're like well also
kind of mind also and I have heard I've
heard of on what's a he's never heard of
famous fighter tell a fight story like I
would tell fight story or that TJ
Dillashaw tell fights where Daniel
Cormier Hotel fight story right but he
shot it in a movie and it was all
scripted all right because III like me
saying I really beat Matt Hughes yeah on
Kingdom yeah well that fight didn't you
tell me he was so ridiculously strong
you've never you were like it was this
tight us alike I grabbed a I grabbed him
we started playing around outside the
trailer and I grabbed him and he he was
he grabbed my head and pulled it down
obviously this is saying nothing but I
was like oh my god any giggles yeah he
sees a girl giggles don't know why you
guys be surprised by the be can you
imagine all of us or talk to like
[ __ ] and then you're like this one
time mean Matt Hughes right hit me in
the nose I thought look when you gotta
fight a fight came under one of these we
also talked about is that when when you
have a trainer so for me my might render
the great Wayne McCullough
Wayne trains me and Wayne loves me and I
love Wayne but we'll have
is after four years Wayne will say
things like when somebody else is around
because he wants to make me look good
Wayne goes he can fight Brian can fight
I want him to fight I want to say I want
you to take a fight you know say that
and then I I start to kind of go you
know he's in the business of also making
sure I stick around and he wants me to
feel good and paying him
you pay him so I acting coach tells me
I'm wrong hey remember when I need mat
using the face the other day I I said to
Wayne ago let's let's let's sometimes
you'll put on gloves a mouthpiece and
we'll just start moving around a little
bit and obviously I do the things I've
learned and I have my things and then he
starts to punch me in the face a little
bit and I go it's just such a reminder
of this guy who's way smaller than me
and what he can [ __ ] do in his sleep
I think here's the other thing you're
trying to do what you learned so what
you should do what you need to do then
is do other things so you need to learn
how to move around the outside of what
you look but you could fight anybody
could have I I'm the same thing as far
as your guys's business you know when
I've had little roles and have to work
with an accent acting coach and she's
worked with everybody and the rock and
being right so and we get done I'd shoot
this audition for and she goes you can
choose you can do this I go yeah I think
I can I've said that tonight oh yeah I
think they said it I said yeah thank you
and she goes no you're gonna be the next
Rahman yeah let's take easiest tell you
down walk it on like maybe this picture
that I caught then I go to acting class
and there's a dramatic scene or I'm on
set and Shia LaBeouf has to do a real
dramatic scene I go I can't do tribal Oh
blah LaBeouf has been doing since he was
a kid liar and he has day me few Amadou
he has a switch with [ __ ] just arming
that yeah
on this honking door machete you want
huh like I have that one move sure
another no you know what
thank God the world so does a lot of
actors yeah some of the most highest
paid people in the bedroom I'm just
saying that me
is not easy to get him a job yes so
there you have it I'm just saying it
goes both ways
absolutely that's a great analogy
sometimes you get wherever you're doing
you don't even comics you know even with
comics it's like you know write
everything every line a long time yeah
everything and then and the Devils in
the details the devil especially what I
love about boxing I came to it late but
I would I respect about it what I love
about it so much the reason I do it
still is the the the difference in those
little details the discipline of being
unless you're some genetic freak but for
the most part like the difference
between where your glove is where it's
here versus here and those are bait by
the way that's just basics Canelo
learned that when he was keep your hands
up that's all and when you see Canal
watching Canelo fight his last fight
with triple G first of all I think he
established himself as one of the greats
but he's such a fundamentally sound
perfect my olace he's flaw was the other
river since he was four they make him
walk around with a soccer ball between
his okay so that's why this is like a
city right like Fran when he puts his
hands down unlike you were I yeah
he's putting him down for a reason get
him to write so that's that's been his
training I didn't know you trained that
but it makes sense there's a reason why
he's the highest paid athlete in the
world for impact the highest paid
athlete in the world you know no I did
he's like I think one of six and one of
some children yeah you know what I loved
about him his distance he made triple G
miss so many part well I think it's
funny and I'm around all these boxer
Mike still work for Showtime right with
I was with Deontay Wilder I was with
fury em being their training camps and
watch them smart I think it's so funny
people go dude he's just a brawler man
like he he has one punch and I'm like oh
he does right you know he's been
fighting since he was 700 say he's just
a brawler knows he chooses to do that
whenever he wants one slightly name a
style cool thing these guys people not
fighters these these guys can do it all
right they can do it all I think Floyd
only fights like this Floyd knows how to
fight like a just a ratioed against
common you know you think I'm just gonna
have my no no I'm gonna come up high now
telling us what the [ __ ] was the star
oh you think I call Baba where people go
Tyson Tyson Fury you know his head
movement and there's no power no no
nobody chooses right he's six eight two
hundred and [ __ ] 60-pound he can
generate moves like a [ __ ] hog why
that when you get hit by his hand it's a
car accident your watch Deontay Wilder
you think it's a mistake just watched 40
and OH 39 knockout I just wanna watch
him he admit something like what the
[ __ ] did you watch I was with him all
day
you are yeah we did in the gym he was in
his training Churchill yeah that's right
shot was over there I went there and he
did his open workout then we did it
interview I think it drops tomorrow on
Showtime we did on top of a
double-decker bus it's fun man oh you
get great interview these guys love you
too I feel like are they crossed you
because you're a fight we get the guard
like I'm not I'm not here to talk about
that you know what you would how you
feeling your game plan I'm like how do
you um that's the fight but it's funny
because you look at his legs are so
widest hands are down no it's all cuts
that we find he's been doing it when he
throws it snaps I'm like I mean it
started in Arizona it came around Texas
and hit the guy in Florida dude he said
he's I'm looking at he's soldiers his
ankles like this he's very super thin
because because a Teddy Atlas said he's
the hardest hitting boxer in in the game
right now
oh for sure yes it's hard but we think
it's harder than then Anthony Joshua yes
anthe Joshua you don't you anti Joshua
doesn't starch guys like if Deonte wall
is the right hand Lance it's oh it's
like over over really and it's just his
God give me a gift and like Anthony
Joshua as a higher guard and he has a
better pedigree when it comes to to his
amateur and a limp Ian but for Gianna a
while there's a better athlete than all
these guys yes all these guys saying I
played football at Alabama like he's a
[ __ ] three yeah he wanted to but his
his dollars born with a horrible disease
he's like that's gonna take too long you
make money I'm gonna be a box
and just start [ __ ] boxing really cuz
I got to pay for this kid in the
insurance and I gotta figure this out
Wow amazing stories it makes great
fighter do you not like him now you know
or Yuri talk with tights in fear a guy
who was 400 pounds retired right and
coke and [ __ ] going away from his
family and he was like do like my wife I
can't believe she put up with it up and
he was 400 pounds and then Saul an
interview were down to water goes he's
[ __ ] done he's not coming back and
fury went excuse me and then went
[ __ ] started getting back in shape
now he's 260 from 400 and he's fighting
his body aunty Walter it's amazing
are you going you're going you're gonna
be their food up so I'm so I was
supposed to work it for a show time I
work in the week of five stand up in New
York the night of the fight I cannot
cancel because that Ricky hadn't hasn't
been missing any meals either he said
about his pig and he fought at 140 set
all the weight cutting boa yeah all the
way coming when she's you know Tyson
times peers one the good guys man I love
most of them are uh yeah all I'm never
really a most every Power Man you even
even the charlo brothers who if you know
charlo jump Jamel and Jamaal badasses on
camera you know they're all what the
[ __ ] - all that dude
off camera great guy and I go do this
man be these guys they're like we don't
we don't know how to do it I remember
you said that you said they asked me
yeah and they're a make these doer
superstars in the [ __ ] it's got any day
now yeah they're like the next big thing
that's it that was again that was kind
of the through line of fight world was
that I'm gonna show you the brother and
sisterhood of fighting and how good
these people are and no one's boring no
one's born they might not be great on a
mic but their stories and and talk about
their childhood no one I could bring any
UFC fighter on my show and below the
belt any single one of them and it's
gonna be a good story yeah so cuz they
might not be together why you think the
UFC has not has not cashed in on that
incredible resource they have like with
a lot of guys they have but I just
stretched so thin there's so many five
so many cards they don't have time to do
all so one so sometimes if I'm the if
I'm the limelight they'd like
got sage Northcutt looks pretty good man
there's CM Punk alright so they go that
but while that lights going they missed
a man in Ennis right who's your first
world champion he gay her and her
girlfriends a UFC fighter and she beat
your cash cow Ronda Rousey but right
we'd even think about that now so yo
hold on hold on and then by the way in a
climate now where how great for 4G
defies all the offer the gay community
to have a woman who is a powerful woman
who is and how but how are they not
rallying around a minute noona is more
how how is she Donna I don't feel bored
outside that's what I keep saying about
the feminist movement these these women
are at the forefront of that [ __ ] at the
forefront of ought but she speaks well
I'll see she is the little broke English
what she speaks well her [ __ ] fiance's
in the UFC as well yeah she beat your
best of all time beat the [ __ ] out of
right and I'm what I just I don't get it
and so now she's fighting cyborg yeah
what happens I there's not a woman on
this planet who beat cyborg yeah she
should beat up most 125s in the offices
yeah
I mean she trains with big dudes and you
got some up scares well I mean watching
her I'm afraid I haven't world champion
have you ever talked to her no her
story's amazing and great person you
would think she'd be all that and now
ladies that's not an optional that is
not a natural way to be you'd write you
know people don't her life is enough
fighting I mean you're not gonna be that
right she's great she had it what's her
story though she she she when does she
get into fighting Chris uh a while I
mean she's been doing forever remember
she was like the first her and Gina
Carano you remember that's like the
first kind of women's fighting in the
strike force days leave exci I mean yeah
it's Holly Holm done no she now she's
won her last fight is she still at
Jackson's camp I think Holly is yeah
with Winkeljohn how about Donald Cerrone
Mike Perry fight do you know what's
going on there Frank uh I think so and
it's it's it's it rings from when I when
when Rashad Evans left it was kind of a
similar so just so the listeners know
and you guys know and you probably don't
know either so when so Rashad Evans when
they read
at Greg Jackson's camp there's like
Rashad Keith Jardine tape Fletcher Nate
Marquardt Donald Cerrone Leonard Garcia
there's no daddy Joe there's like a crew
of them Diego Sanchez I go Santa [ __ ]
Michelle Waterson and Holly Holly Holm
so there's a crew that's you're a Pierre
was there too they came a little out
that was the [ __ ] crew yeah
and then you know Rashad was doing his
fights there and he's always going down
there's his camp and then a young cat
named John Jones comes along yeah and
Jackson's takes him under his wing and
then Rashad goes dude we're in the same
weight class we have to [ __ ] fight
you got a pic I can't train with this
guy and it's like in defense well no he
don't wants a lifetime talent I'm
driving like now right and and but but
it's it's tough because and that's that
was the rule I don't know how it is
there and in Gregg's camp but but you
know their teammates never fought each
other that was a rule like you can't
fight each other but the UFC made that
go out the window you should go excuse
me right hilarious right yes you can
fight each other on the car otherwise
you're [ __ ] right you win a bear you on
the undercard so then guys from a K
we're having to fight each other guys
from a TT you have to fight each other
then Jacksons eventually cuz you get
these big camps they have the best guys
in weight class you're seagulls I don't
give a flying [ __ ] about you guys figure
it out right you guys are fighting right
it was a it was a there's a real big
loyalty was a lot of thing so then were
shot bounces stretched Blackzilians it
comes to denver ease with us all the
time and then with cowboy which is
recent
so cowboy was there he's never been a
Winkeljohn guy he was trained as greg
jackson then he had his own guys and so
cowboy stars on muy Thai guy he's ranch
he started the the [ __ ] cowboy ranch
where the [ __ ] is my ranch so he started
just doing his training there he's don't
schedule stuff like that they come in
spar at Jacksons but he's a staple of
Jackson's evening Greg's always been in
his corner he helped build that house in
a way I'm correct yes Julie resigned
about the only reason I went because
being cowboy friends he'd bring up dad
to live with him and stay with him
anyways so Mike Perry who's a phenomenal
fighter
decides to go to Jackson's down in
Cowboys like well [ __ ] hope we never
have to fight and then they the UFC say
K you two are fighting and then cowboy
goes to Gregg and goes oh dude he got
trained here you guys know me better
than anyone
you have seniority and like no he's
gonna train here
that's ridiculous [ __ ] this get that
pounces him and Winkeljohn have never
liked each other so Cowboys been on his
own now and now Mike Perry's been
training at Jacksons which anyone who
knows Donald Cerrone and you've seemed
trained enough you know the holes in his
game you can get it from tape but no one
on the planet knows dawn sir only better
in Greg Jack's
no one and Winkeljohn yeah so they're
training Mike Perry and he's fighting in
Denver at Cowboys home town Saturday
night I think this little [ __ ] up
[ __ ] up yeah yeah because but then
like a lot of fighters at Jacksons came
out with dogs never been like he's
always done his own thing he's never
been here for us I know but it's always
about but yeah but but also but I'm
sorry but you may say that but Donald
Cerrone is I think the most winning one
of the most winning I mean he's been at
the top of the game for 10 year doesn't
matter he did help build that house but
when I think Jackson's I think it's all
Cerrone II well a lot of us do I mean I
mean obviously here's thing Diego
Sanchez was there before any of them
Diego's doing came out with no hold on
brother you're never here
when you don't have a fight you're not
here helping us so I see both story
right I'm obsolete I'm a dog Cerrone guy
I lost my [ __ ] yeah I wanted to win this
fight for some reason he's older his
career here's all this going against
them you know I'm a Mike Perry fan at
the end it's also a terrible matchup for
Donald to be honest why is that Donald
when Donald can't be the bully it's a
tough fight for him you mean the guy
said when you can go forward on Donald
and punch and box it's a like Nate Diaz
it's a long night for Donald yeah well
what's Mike Perry - yeah he's aggressive
puncher and who goes forward and anyone
that Jack's ago hey you want to be
Donald you draw a line in the sand you
[ __ ] charge right do not let him
throw black also Donald's a slow starter
so you come out the [ __ ] gate at him
yeah he likes to he likes to kind of
feel the nerves yeah it's the nerves
Donald takes a while to get going he's
always been a slow started right unless
you're Melvin gilyard who [ __ ] jumped
at the gun and Donald taught him knocked
him out other than that Dom Dom's a very
slow starter right if you in Jackson's
camp kill hey this way he's gonna do
this way then do it's like oh that is
[ __ ] up yes I just don't know
it's a business I don't want to know
it's a business yeah it is a business
right how old is Ellie oh you say Mike
Perry yeah uh he's a [ __ ] he had like
his career was skywriting then he lost
too pricey well his last one against
Felder right he looked amazing his first
fight at Jacksons he's he's [ __ ] good
in only 27 yeah and he's just coming to
his own well I think I feel like he's he
looked like he had made big changes with
the felder fight you looked amazing now
against happy it didn't look like he was
but then before that you know he lost a
fight see he lost a putz and a bo which
was a big one for him and then he lost
to max Griffin and then he destroyed
Jake Ellenberger I was a rough one to
watch but a lot of times when he fights
guys to a real technical can don't play
that game with him like Alan Joe ban
right you know they can stand outside
and not get knocked out but then I
thought the same things happen with Paul
failed her and he mixed it up footwork
angles kicks takedown like you looked
amazing yes he did so I don't know just
went a long rant about [ __ ] Greg
Jackson's but yeah yeah I don't know
again I don't mean you know I've been so
out of that everybody has their side of
the story you know everybody has their
the only thought the only problem there
is when when a lot of Greg Jack's and
fighters come out in defense of the gym
go hold up cowboy you haven't been here
brother right that's why we said and
remember it's just not Winkeljohn and
Greg going yeah we're good the team has
to take him it's right but so that's
where I'm like all right maybe and you
know a cowboy has a fighter you are
selfish guy and he's doing his life
you're riding horses and jump out of
planes and [ __ ] during his all right
maybe he wasn't there but at the same
time your home has always been there and
that's where you that was your training
camp right and also don't work your wins
your wins go doesn't work like that
health no one cares but don't try the
way you oh don't it's an individual
sport yes it is it's a team but don't
your wins your wins though also
obviously the Jackson Winkeljohn camp
has some great fighters not just Donald
Cerrone it's John Jones it's it's he who
stands is the best day of the best so so
he's a part of that but his wins also
lent lent a great deal to the reputation
of the but a ton of guys can say that
but again Jackson
team don't care about that they have did
Alistair Overeem their Frank Mir running
hunter a lot Travis Browne Rashad George
st. I mean the rosters did they the
question is they probably said you're
welcome to train here but we're also
training my Perry here is that is that
kind of howl when are they had no know
how the true fighters gonna train in the
same camp so they basically said ok I
don't know
I had the man by the way also I did
overhear Greg Jackson say he hated you
me why what did I do
your [ __ ] who change there's playing
kahlan think she doesn't like any
jujitsu he does like mighty bull you yet
he's here by my box at least he said
something said he thinks you could box
apples or oranges that's not I think
that's good I like my favorite thing is
the Robert Evans quote there there are
three sides to every story your side my
side and the truth
and nobody's lying everybody's got a
point of view and I love Greg Jackson me
to a nice guy ever we it's great to
minify wink wink so dedicated sport he
lost a [ __ ] I hold admits of spaz
kicked him in the eye with his one eye
is one eye
[ __ ] that's rocks so he's named weakness
[ __ ] my toenail am i wrong is that
not wire can't tell which one yeah yeah
the great white eyed on the left he's
half great white shark yeah he's half
blue shut up summer to lose your goddamn
eye yeah so give them in a little slack
yeah get lost if you said Brian here's a
billion dollars but you don't have your
left eye like oh I guess I go no I will
you're full of [ __ ] I don't want to took
me a billion look straight cash look I
got a dude I'd wear a [ __ ] pass I
don't have a vote you that I mean beyond
it I'd wear a pass for sure but would
you do it for a billion 1 billion just
the left yeah yeah yeah I would be I
don't like what I see anyway especially
in here I think first of all my eyes are
part of my by the way I saw your
favorite guest Michael Rapaport at the
Soho House the other day and I I had my
my impetus was to go up and say hello
because we kind of know each other
through you guys yeah and I just didn't
have the energy he's a lot of energy
better be ready to go when his here at
that's great he's a [ __ ] shoe jump
some current event he's it toasty it's
[ __ ] here it is hot what time he
gives off a lot of heat I do I'm very
frank his chest 119 it's 1 9 20 well how
much I gotta go soon already haven't we
been here for an hour we've been here
for exactly an hour yeah yeah just about
now as your pain man you want see this
fighting one real quick though you want
in current events and we'll be done
Frank sure all right this one so for
male with her and tension knuckle now
sue Kawa there's a big announcement
they're supposed to fight and risin and
as of today Floyd Mayweather seems to be
backing out makes sense after doing a
whole press conference hold you're
skeptical hippo eyes here as soon as
gallant something sketch here and here's
the thing I won't say my source but a
guy who's very high up at a network that
I work for who is usually a business
partner with Floyd was I kidding yeah I
asked him before any of this came out as
far as Floyd saying he's unhappy I went
to was he doing he goes because he
usually if he's gonna do something he
hits up me it's up this guy and no one's
heard from ego so I don't know because
it sounds like some shady business I
know like this doesn't seem real right
it was talk well no he got no no no how
did you read the story no yeah yeah
honeydicked he went out there and he
thought it was gonna be just a [ __ ]
9 minute exposition of three rounds
okay and like I just in for real like
for real like high up like whales
wealthy ballers wealthy periodic you
just do a special bout for entertainment
person purposes and he goes with no
intention of being represented as an
official fight card for televised
worldwide
he was once I arrived to the press
conference my team and I were completely
derailed by a new direction this event
was going and we should have put a stop
to it immediately I want to sincerely
sincerely apologize to my face
and for misleading information that was
announced during the press conference
because I guess he got there and you
know obviously don't speak English so he
was like oh cool we're doing this and
then me and trimmer watched him was for
you guys can you watch him through there
and he's kind of like the questions he's
like what when they go what the way
cutters will figure that out it's not a
big deal but you can see he looks like a
like he's been taken hostage by Isis and
they're forcing him to say some [ __ ]
play that chin I mean you could just see
his face is what he is and he's unhappy
money is the motivation well we all know
that um I had a great career you know
was very truly blessed you know to be in
a sport a long time and to make over a
billion a billion dollars in the sport
and to make smart investments likes know
we're fighting this would be great for
the sport yeah he's literally like a
diplomat yeah he's like wait what yeah
and then it's an exhibition if that's
what he thought they were gonna do so he
landed back in it because you know your
cooze or whatever was like you're
fighting [ __ ] that yeah no problem
we'll see a end of December then as soon
as he got his private [ __ ] jet and
touched down in LA he's like [ __ ] this
and got on social media I was like this
ain't happenin yeah everyone around his
circle and around the guys that I know
we're like this is something fishy said
he's smart enough to say anything during
the conference know the reason why he's
a billion dollar fighters cuz the
smartest have you ever been around him
know he's the smartest fighter I've ever
seen in my life like you saw it I could
saw like he's now it's all a show oh
everything like during the McGregor
Floyd fight when they when they're just
doing the press conference before they
do all access like I need camera a over
here and they be here now you're when I
halfway through you're gonna come here
and literally just wow he knew the
schematic Oh bro everything every file
and then after you like okay then I'm
gonna go here I'm gonna sit down with
Showtime I'm gonna do 5 min an interview
with there when I'm done there and then
just it's not like some was like hey
Floyd you're hearing no he was like
and then when you hear them talk to
Tesla it's not accidental no long-term
right right when you see somebody who's
able to stay relevant and keep it going
and you meet them in person I don't give
a [ __ ] who it is right it's always
amazing yeah I learned that on MADtv
when I met rappers that had been around
a long time weather was LL Cool J Queen
Latifah MC Lyte whatever was back then I
had an idea of what a rapper was I just
did I was it wasn't a prejudiced idea
but it was a it was an idea right it was
a strong idea that a rapper was somebody
who would probably come late somebody
who had a diva complex somebody whatever
was just as a black yesterday it was it
was what it was like they would ever get
I was a and then I was around them and I
watched them work and I watched the ones
that were doing it I was like oh you're
smart as it's not an axe it's not only
you smartest [ __ ] but your discipline is
fun you just have the same thing across
all boards Walt's a fighter actor
stand-up comedian whatever it is this
man it's their work ethic and their
discipline is what there's no accident
no there's no accident nope and that's
why I love that book outliers just
because it's yeah you realize that your
eyes even the people I don't like the
athletes are the actors whoever it is I
think they got lucky and I don't think
they're talented yes Laura Sam it's
ridiculous of course they're talented
and they've been in this they've been at
this a long time and if somebody does
get lucky and hits if you don't maintain
some aspect of old hard work and
discipline you're gonna go away you
worked with Sean Penn and didn't you
tell me that you were you your script is
all marked up because you had notes
because when you work you know it's an
actor one things you don't know is
actors like when you come to a set every
line has has a business around it right
so it means something else as a thought
the line is a breath every on and so
he's Frank is a [ __ ] workhorse like
that he'll take a script and he gets
nuts about it and he breaks it all
that's called breaking down the script
and any actors worth their salt when you
show up and you're working with God with
what Frank's working with people like
Naomi Watts
Oscar winners like you know Mel Gibson
of Sean Penn and he said that he's there
with Sean Penn and he's there doing the
table read and he's his script is all
marked up and he looks over at Sean Penn
and Sean Penn scripted
also yeah yeah and it's yeah of course
and it's you know it's it is it's how
much you put into it yeah you know it's
like okay I think with Floyd too like I
went in with a preconceived notion like
god this guy hits women he's just an
idiot he's just a really good boxer like
something stupid so I went in and with
all access team and someone goes hey man
because because they only let like six
people and they're on Showtime's then
and then
showtimes can't get in there like we
want you ask him a question and the
before I was kind of nervous I was like
this [ __ ] idiot and someone goes hey
man last time Floyd if he doesn't
recognize you he didn't kick you out in
front everyone just she want you to be
aware displayed to it she was dealing
she was just want you to be aware like
if he doesn't recognize you and he
thinks it's Kim you're gonna ask
something that he doesn't know he's in
kick out for everyone so don't be
offended I was like oh no doubt so I was
a little nervous kind of like God look
at this [ __ ] and so he sits down and
he just starts going through everything
and like two minutes I'm like oh [ __ ]
this guy is the real deal
he's it wasn't like a billion dollar
wasn't like when I was that like UFC
scrum stuff like that when I was
involved with him where you're just like
all right what do you guys got no no he
[ __ ] was like this is how it's going
down this is what we're doing this is
the magnitude like literally just told a
story there's no questions really my
only question were I had some lame
question about Justin Bieber but
whatever you say get the [ __ ] out like
right away sir yeah that was a weird
thing what were they hanging out and
learning beer we're friends yeah yeah
when you're that famous it's like a
small circle yeah yeah where no one
needs anything from you right so I think
that's why it happened again there's
another guy Justin Bieber it's like
people make fun of him cuz he's the
Biebs and then but guess what he's
talented so [ __ ] Jonas you worked with
Nick Jonas and I watched the Ascension
of Nick yeah when he came on to kingdom
which he barely got on I mean you know
we if I had my druthers in the beginning
of casting it wouldn't have been Icke
Johnny because you have an idea one idea
that has a little boy band a kid and
yeah you know nothing better yeah and
then he came in with 30 other dudes and
he read with me he was the last one
I've told us through a thousand times
but he was
he was the best really by far and he
worked harder than everybody there you
go right and when he left I looked at
him I looked everybody go he got the job
it's his job he's a monster yeah and and
then then he became Nick Jonas a solo
singer while he was on Kingdom and I
watched that ascension and how hard he
he'd go from working with me from 6 a.m.
to 6 p.m. and working then go to the
studio he'd be on working on an album
working out learning you know trying to
learn fighting it was like all day the
kid was working you know so such a town
you got a respect he plays every
instrument pretty much he's a he's a
beautiful and kid yes great person yeah
good sense of humor too what else yet
Jen oh so a local doughnut shop in Seal
Beach both of the owners are married
Cambodian immigrants the wife had an
aneurysm she's currently in the hospital
locals found out about it and are buying
doughnuts out super early in the morning
so the husband can go be with her at the
hospital
damn that's cool man and they're selling
out of the donut
mm-hmm that's cool that's communities
this seal Beach California
yep that's a Cambodian community
probably the shops are Cambodian yeah
that's really cool what their donors
really I think the normal like yummy
donuts like Generic have you had what is
it called um so that they don't not
unschooled I forgot to say this
they brought a doughnut truck where they
make the doughnuts from scratch and
they're on Santa Monica psycho Santa
Monica psycho sidecar is that what it is
yeah hold on
yeah no it's do them oh it's this
another four five years here it's the
butter and butter and salt this late to
every gay dude Oh Mikey Donnie come on
not in a sidecar right he goes like car
don't stop Santa model he goes weights
amazing sends a demonic incentivize are
those Levi's look nice make yeah that is
yes sorry Wes is into shoes that's a
sidecar that's it's the best I've ever
had in my life laughs you know by the
hands dude have you other doughnut holes
yes I freaked out though that today they
were making them guys that have paleo
that would
they brought that truck on my [ __ ]
set and he was and I go I'm not eating
to us and she was rolling them out and
the woman had looking I tried it that
Bradley Cooper yes it is the cinnamon
what the cinnamon butter or whatever the
best holy [ __ ]
GameChanger I'm freaking out doughnut oh
my god the best it's so good the best
doughnuts I couldn't take it you're so
good
[ __ ] blue star together they can all
suck my dick compared to that that one
too
that's about huckleberry yes it is some
[ __ ] I'll be good I want that right now
and they were hot I'm talking too loudly
but I freaked out yeah yeah so I've been
going for five years so it's whatever
Dave Frank well let's go then watch
Frank not eat doughnuts you'll be like I
don't bring your diet all the time still
eyes it's not really consider it a diet
I just don't eat doughnuts
and I buy them for my kids on the
weekend what do you what do you eat just
like lettuce and honey jerky or some
[ __ ] no I know gratitude I ki toast Oh
Pelly oh yeah yeah sure city man uh what
else eh in this one so on a Polish
variety show a contestant came on to
prefer hotline bling and he decided to
do it looking like this and he was a
white guy before all this white guy
polish let me see this kinda looks like
this is all my chimera got Stalin or
something
[Music]
the crowd has no problem with it it's
not a history of it it's terrible
he's not really singing though yeah he's
not he's singing he's singing yeah you
like it it sounds like he's a little
slow though huh
[Music]
no he's a white guy who paid himself
black frames he's doing blackface yeah
he's doing blackface I think it's about
the greatest thing I've ever seen in my
life
I use the answers in the background I
think here's a touch of the downs
there's something missing they're
missing he did get a double thumbs up
from rich Donnelly you mean yeah whoa
there is that I was a bunch of like Oh
their sake is all people are just up as
someone that's a that looks like it yeah
that crowd din let's go ahead and see
the Brazilian TV though the girls are
the pasties and I want to know that you
can get a virus keep one oh yeah you
want some more he's young guys get more
rational and smarter than you because
you think with your emotional brain oh
dude you're an expert was that my
amygdala working let's call him let's
just call it the Amy okay
so singer Sinead O'Connor recently
became a Muslim and she came out and
said that she does not want to have
anything to do with disgusting white
people anymore Sinead O'Connor my
favorite kind of people wow she's these
people [ __ ] crazy
she's sick mentally though yeah she
thought threatened suicide honestly she
found something where she's gonna keep
on keepin on you know why don't you [ __ ]
Muslim here so she said I I'm terribly
sorry
what I'm about to say is something so
racist I never thought my soul could
ever feel it but I truly but truly I
never want to spend time with white
people again if that's what non-muslims
are called not for one moment for any
reason they are disgusting instead see
if Twitter bans this when it allows
people like Trump and Milbank to spew
the satanic filth upon Eve
in my country she's not well yeah
forgive me sometimes the Lord needs
dirty workers hashtagged not as [ __ ]
crazy as she well that's what that's
well hashtag even crazier than I thought
well yeah that's what Isis does they go
I'm gonna kill this village I'm gonna
cut their throats not cuz god this
droughts works as God's Word so she's
behaves their jobs dirty work yeah yeah
so if they're there discussing what me
what the next step when you say somebody
a group of people are disgusting is that
we don't have to be removed and that
next step is we kill them now it's bad
but don't worry because what we're
actually doing is cleaning the world of
disgusting people it's as old as time
which is where I read history you
realize she's not original this is a
white person let's get rid of why she's
a crazy she's whiter than what she's
gonna loosen that's a white sheet yeah
sinead o'connor's she I'm not gonna vote
for her if she runs for office I guess
that's what I'm trying to plan out
buying their next album like you in the
eighties like you in the 80s and now
maybe just always it like to be in the
eighties that was important what is your
name sure why is it her name Shahada cuz
you got a name like Lindsay Lohan
everyone Lindsay Lohan's trying to save
this kitchen dick please please how kind
of bad you know that yeah it was like
we're the [ __ ] yeah she's a little crazy
you see Lindsay Lohan she hasn't like
the Middle East she has the Middle
Eastern accent accent she does Alex
pasok she lives in the Middle East
yeah she's married no she dated it a guy
who was from the Middle East and then
she got an accent yeah and then she was
like trying to say no please please
become analyst
what you're a nihilist man yeah well
whatever anyway oh yeah so the FDA is
approving a new opioid that even the FDA
advisory committee said they warned
against it's called to sue via mm-hmm
it's ten times stronger than fentanyl
Jesus and deaths overdose so I'm like
that's some crazy like that a crooked
businessman so you do realize this right
well what is this this might be for
something very very important it's for
hardcore you know it's hardcore pain and
it's supposed to be only for medical
facilities and doctors just to do their
I'm sure
it has a good well I'll tell you
something I'm in hardcore pain but the
Advisory Committee thinks that it's
gonna get outside of that it's a they
called divertible yeah of course and
they say they think that within the
first few months there will be a lot of
deaths people but it was approved with
some powerful chemicals that's crazy man
yeah what else you got Jen you want some
more yeah Attorney General just retired
oh that's freaking awesome yeah today
Democrat while in the house right that I
believe the Democrats won the house they
Allison control the Senate still so it's
still you know yeah
okay carried away they didn't win it
Xbox that's night there's Mario Mello he
choked to death doing a croissant eating
contest X Pro Bowler sorry mellow chokes
death and a croissant eating contest
croissants are dry bro this is him dying
yeah but it hit very very bad to watch
let me see it wait just pride false down
yeah it's just a lot of panic see it's
really sad to watch they're trying out
like no one knows the Heimlich it won't
come out and me I'm like there's a
doctor and a firefighter that was in the
crowd that ran up to him but they didn't
have any like professionals and you know
you saw the situation is [ __ ] up you
actually cut right here and put a straw
in the trachea and breathe for the
person oh good luck with that with that
I think I've got to go do you know that
that's what you do well you try the
Heimlich first guys unfortunately I'm
going to do legs I carry you are
I carry a straw and a small razor frank
grillo we all do Reed's anyways Frankie
Frankie Frankie for fight world is the
show on my world on Netflix you can
watch every episode it's unbelievable
that was the best yeah really thank you
sir for coming on but I'd like to talk
about some of the movies I have come
home kid I understand what are the
movies go go best brother rage against
the night my friend and get your legs
strong 405 congratulations
ass to grass Frank yeah I want to feel
that look at that damn it's super damp
and there's some poo and right here is
where Frank Grillo leaves and feel
Vaughn makes a surprise visit
today yeah well that was Frank Grillo
but good news Theo von just stepped
stopped in to say hello he goes I'm just
gonna bother you guys and he's here to
do just a couple things I guess he's
gonna do a couple of impressions the oh
well can you do I think you have a
crystal imprint you just burst in here
oh my god good - oh my god bad jeez
that's so bad is that Chris dude my his
hair is longer than mine and it's true I
swear to God for a second I thought that
was Chris D'Elia oh my god I'm so on it
now what would be can you do an
impression of like say me let me see
Bryan Callen yeah Chalabi / that's me
that's amazing romanian beekeeper i said
I thought you'd try for sale yeah I
thought is there to counsel yes why were
you going like this with your finger up
in the air like holding the world
Oh somebody's gotta do it
Brendon that's so good
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's almost like candy [ __ ] with us
always doesn't he like nine hold my leg
Brendan good do you have a Brendan
impression let me see um this is so
spot-on
Wow yeah do you feel like you just heard
you'd obviously like Brendan I used your
sponsor life now I'm just joking guy
that's kind of mean no it wasn't me it
was really good
well what are you doing together not
much man
actually you've all been out of gas when
I pulled on him a lot so I've got a I'm
waiting on the gas guy gotta for that
out have to pay him yeah yeah I do
actually do you do what do you do during
the day do you work out do you have a
hobby besides I keep going usually yeah
I get going how was Buffalo decent our
Buffalo is good it's a cool spot right
oh yeah you get some chicken wings uh
nope I didn't do anything man I walk
down the street stay out of the haunted
hotel like legit haunted oh they wanted
me to come there in the winter but I
can't just can't do it do you can handle
it bro no I can't my skin cracks yeah my
skin's a little too old you can buy
another layer off I mean do you han
Duras bro my sister looked at me the
other day she looked at my face and she
went like this I go what he don't you
guys I'm looking at your face and I well
okay and she goes you need to drink a
lot of water Wow I go woody nice because
it just looked like somebody took all
the water
Stevi hasn't seen you a while when when
you went to the bathroom goes is Brian
eating yeah he's always tell me I don't
eat enough yeah maybe you could have
different stuff Brennan does look a
little bit healthier thanks dude they
should have a health meter behind each
one of you guys where it's like this and
stress meter yeah
those dopes though right yeah Buffalo
was good man a lot good open I forget
the guys name older dude big guy works
at a Correctional Facility no I don't
think I got a kind of a chubby guy look
like a look like they do from Rascal
Flatts but was like hilarious not
hilarious
oh nice guy though definitely seem like
a nice guy maybe a guy like a mate like
kind of like a Maitre D' it like a Dave
& Buster's I do it but should be doin
sanity not be doing a Stan he's gonna
hear this sometimes you really you
started home I said he's a great guy
till he seemed like a nice guy - nice
hair yeah I think it was him Gary livox
that's pretty cool yeah maybe he's
starting maybe he just needs some time I
got looks like Guy Fieri's dick look at
that guy
I can't look taking a [ __ ] eraser
that's happy to mean you're right
actually I got seemed like a decent guy
look at him he's talent though like a
[ __ ]
Oh extreme is a highway I wanna ride it
all night long you know I used to come
to this room you Brian's never heard
that so why would you come to that side
of the highway the highway
I'll just hidden rest areas at the house
what's the weirdest thing you said when
you when you uh you know guys I gotta go
I used to say I'm sorry when I come I'm
sorry
yeah my bad I go but I'm that early
comer dude if you find me in some [ __ ]
I haven't
- nobody does in America and somebody
like me that's good I'm horrible at sex
rope each alopecia alopecia I'm not
losing my hair like that I got I didn't
take my brother's do you mean we're yet
this weekend dude uh this weekend I'll
be in Salt Lake City it's already sold
out
you know wise guys yeah I'm excited
you've been there I was just lucky
Keith Stubbs the owner yeah he just the
best yeah I was there two weekends ago
Keith is cool I love that Club we're out
after that I'm excited
after at Lexington Kentucky in December
sold out nope Lexi book club is the
comedy off Broadway yeah
mmm is there a Broadway out there in
their I've been there what happened oh
is that I've been there
oh yeah what happened that's what Paul
Revere win no I was thinking about out
no you went too is that's fine Alabama
don't think of that sorry that's that's
that's that's maybe Nassau yeah that's
Alaba NASA's in Alabama D can you
believe that yeah I saw a guy in Alabama
walking around with an ak-47 and you're
allowed to carry that really I'm not
kidding I saw him walking with a gun
he's probably a father of strapped
around I got a salt rifle he probably
has a couple children out in the open
dude it's Hedy down there this huge
animals down there did you lose a kid to
a wild boar on a nature hike I mean
that's kind of Terry ak-47 Ella baby's
heart beat up people biting and you
should always be strapped yeah Texas -
oh yeah I'm sure coming out probably
when I was there they were doing
construction so maybe they've built it
up a little bit put it pull up coming
out Broadway there was a leak when I was
there laughing I said you're on video of
my experience there was a leak inside
yes something like that so I I was there
when it wasn't
Laurette ikan it was going through a
transition there you go yeah it looks
like a real Trap House huh
I don't know it looks like it danny's I
shouldn't [ __ ] on it cuz I'm sure I'll
be there like a few months after there
are a number of but Lexington Kentucky
is pretty cool
oh yeah Lexington is a really cool City
yeah Jared Lorenzen came out to the show
last time always he I remember him pass
who's we hundred pounds yeah
that big Jimmy sure do a podcast with
him out there gonna be a bad idea it's
good idea
quarterback people probably left hear
what he's up to yeah he was like a
700-pound quarterback he's doing
something cool now he's the star right
for Kentucky like 300 pounds play for
the Giants for a little bit mm-hmm I
think he's playing some he's even bigger
now I have you know no is he so there's
like a 30 for 30 he's playing like like
Arena League 7 or some [ __ ] what's his
name
Aaron Lorenzen yep that's it Jared
generally get so big before you just go
back to heaven dude that's how God works
there's limits on the human body
oh and he like to push those limits yeah
that's him as the starting quarterback
at 300 pounds from what in sec Wow
that's a big foul imagine now there's a
reason why quarterbacks aren't 300
pounds because they have trouble ambling
out of the way to the left now oh and
he's playing professional football
though mm-hmm
and he's playing professional oh no no
well he did play professional okay you
can see his skin asking God for help
yeah that's a wasa big goal that's a guy
who likes to eat he's just a big boy he
looks like a human version of a bulldog
English Bulldog Bulldog he looks like he
has my eyes but I'm 51 you wish you had
those eyes why he has handsome eyes
probably his blue eyes I can't see him
is what I'm saying I call him a baby
blue bull my eyelids seem to be falling
and covering my and I need to get my
eyelids do you know what he looks like
he smells well really don't you think I
call him little Wyoming the dude is huge
he's so big little Wyoming yeah yeah he
looks like a big fella he had a [ __ ]
cannon for an arm yeah yeah he's
obviously a healthy dude his arm
somebody said one of his arms weights 70
pounds how crazy is that
is that true yeah how crazy his arm
she's 300 pounds his arm worried 7240
pounds arms that's amazing yep now
that's he's doing disasters
let's implant for the river monster you
know the team over there
for dessert bro what are you talking
about well that's him now he's it here
and I'll say this one of the nicest guys
to man have to ripped him up didn't
wanna show dude
oh yeah um don't eat me oh yeah that tip
man I gotta go go you're going to
Kentucky and I'm going to the kentucky
of california I'm going to Sacramento
are you really yeah dude everybody it
looks like a missing person dude you
could just go around any way you could
put anybody on a wanted poster there and
it [ __ ] anyone on a milk carton oh I
know that guy
everybody that looks like a missing
person Oh everybody one looks like the
other set of first 48 dude I'm telling
you man I've been doing this a long time
I when I was watching you in Phoenix it
was inspiring I started writing Oh your
stand-up your new [ __ ] everything you're
doing is beautiful
you're the best brother few guys having
me man think good as it gets as good as
it gets think of on go see him cuz it's
a treat you're truly original go seam in
Kentucky cuz thanks Frank wise guys just
sold out did you guys ever do Foxwoods
or not
Foxwoods yeah was that it is that casino
twice you have yeah no it's in
Connecticut it's a great it's a great
it's a it's a great gig it is it's a
short flight yeah you know you'll fly in
a Hartford then you'll drive about an
hour so I can remember how we're not
flying a I think New Haven anyway you'll
figure have you done New Mexico I'm
doing I think Santa Fe have you done
that yet Joey Diaz did told me the Dutch
dreamcatcher country dude
a lot of green chile bro I'm trying to
[ __ ] my pants was a lot of people making
dream catchers over there that's what
I'm saying a lot of people like dream
catchers that don't work I must sell
dream catchers at the show that I'm
doing that you know I really instead
like he really has a brother that's a
scary thing you know he dresses up like
another guy his brothers one of my
favorite people did you really I [ __ ]
loved his brother the Caleb J if J lived
here I would spend most of my time with
him I'm not joking well nice guy huh
he's not just a nice guy he's super
smart and he like whenever you're with
him like he knows everything
no no he knows everything oh and by the
way down the [ __ ] hang no matter what
2:00 in the morning wherever you want I
got him for a drink you guys sure and
then he'll wake up at 5:00 well all the
merch everything's him yeah he's a nice
guy huh what's it every swing him I'm
Brandon he's a smart guy
well it's Brendan sorry Brendan my bad
dude my vowels are Brandon Brandon yours
it is when they set back and clock my
tongue gets tricky
what is the difference we knew in him
Jay is Jay Jay is Jay has something
really special Jay has the confidence to
sit there and be a spectator and not
want to be involved he doesn't need the
limelight well he's on this gram but
he's not posting pictures he's just not
trying to make videos or sell no no and
he's there for that for the cause of my
sick if you get in my argument with Jay
about sports or anything if you get in
an argument I've seen that I know you're
shaming and Brandon mmm-hmm
you better know your [ __ ] because I'm
gonna tell you right now you don't know
more than he does well and he's gonna
win the argument like Brendan's pretty
alpha and kind of Brendan will concede
an argument you lose then like he'll
lose to him so if it's play you'll get
right in yeah but any other fighting
like wrong point of view will have a
strong point and knows his [ __ ] yeah he
knows he'll say something to you like
like he'll say something then you'll go
you never thought of in the argument
right yeah oh yeah he's smart or but
I'll get you know he's seen every one of
my sets he's been on the every show I've
ever done he's seen every single set
I'll get done I'll go what do you think
he's the only guy who all listen to ya
what do you think he'll go not your best
there you go
then you know it's not your exactly does
he offer insights and stuff to have
ideas no no no never but that's cool
though he's not he's not the creative
type like that but he knows when it's a
good knows when it works when it doesn't
yeah that's cool you get to get like
Frankie Frankie that's great why on the
road to me that's I don't bring opens I
just bring him but but this is gonna
sell me my buzz chilling hanging out in
the cities yes going around sort of an
opener I said let me put it this way he
said to me he saw he watched my special
twice hmm and he said to me that you
know he was very complimentary
that the fact that he liked it that much
meant as much to me as anybody out there
well I've had a lot of people in the
business a because I know like I respect
his opinion yeah so that was it
respectable guy I look forward to
meeting him yeah you bet you'll be
working especially as we do more show
still yeah like stinging the King or we
do on the road again
like he was gonna come to Phoenix but I
was doing something but he deal all the
merch like we
you know I wish I is a sister that
changed my brother and when I'm with
them I go hey brothers
well hey brothers yeah did he just say
what do you say about my sister that did
your sister that looks like your brother
that's actually not sure you bought I'm
just kidding that's every good laugh
really
no sir buy at school every day and the
kids are come from the older school get
picked up first and they would come and
my brother and all the friends and I
throw my notice wait taller than me
short hair carried a baseball glove with
very short a baby well she was obviously
did she have a dick I had a conversation
with Joey Diaz had a conversation with
Joey Diaz you're just on his podcast
right but I come say to enjoy Diaz i
watch this special degenerates on
Netflix and I called him to tell cuz I
was listening on Rogen and I said what
makes Joey Diaz so special you're in the
same kind of category is your guys's
memories did your memory to be able to
go back when there are certain details
about your childhood and all the stories
that's what makes you guys such great
comedians like joy Diaz or drop us story
he's never heard before anybody got
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah 82 I was in and
you're like an 82 yeah like I can
identify in 82 but then her name the guy
who sold him the sandwich yeah exactly
what he bought at the sandwich place
what he didn't get on his sandwich what
that guy said to him then his buddies
outside her name all the guys and he's
going through it it just hit me like
[ __ ] man his memories so ridiculous
wonder how that happens to people why
they need that like way don't get
punched in the face like I remember yes
I didn't get that makes a damn
I don't know any details if you asked me
what year you and I met I wouldn't have
a [ __ ] clue Rogan is really good at
it too but different good you and joy
can go back the rolodex and like always
a master but you're getting good to open
and you'll you'll say something and
it'll trigger something in my childhood
[ __ ] I remember that and it helps me
with my [ __ ] yeah but listen to Joey I'm
like [ __ ] and I I call my dude your
special is so good man your memory is
you have the best marry anyone I know
you would if you gave what if Brian
worked as your memory and sat on your
shoulder and just told you all your
memories of your past and like let me
told everybody monsters if you keep
losing weight and you keep gaining
weight it could happen okay and I'm just
like the skeleton you're as conscience
yeah yeah I'm thinner I'm just the thin
man on ass in you go cuz you have to cut
some of your shoulders and legs off but
you could do it yeah yeah or I just like
get I just wither and I'm just on and
I'm like dog or you're like I'm a
ventriloquist and I put my hand up your
[ __ ]
oh so small and then I when I go like
this you go I don't want to do that part
I don't like no I want to know you said
you run ass play into it and I just want
to be attached to your back and I'll go
like this like when you're about to make
a bad decision you just hear me go
careful oh no dude I'll be like a big
old mama kangaroo and put you in a pouch
in the front you're so stupid small and
then whatever i stupid pop up we go and
pop down I don't know cuz I don't get
claustrophobic yeah that's right yeah I
don't want to be a marsupial [ __ ]
pouch I want to be on your back like the
monkey on your back and I go all like
picking ass out of my head like this and
if you're getting close to the answer I
go getting warm up that'd be cool you
know what I mean yeah you guys got to
grow up man I gotta get out of here
alright love you man ladies and
gentlemen a bonus enema a bonus handling
with Theo von
thanks for the impression that the Nike
and Pumas you were in my day please
there is one squawk dude where I come
from you were Nike saw its with Puma
shoes you got beat up it's the first
thing I noticed on people if you were a
Nike
with a Reebok you got bullied at
screaming oh dude you kidding me you got
you know you don't wear two different
companies on your feet bro damn I get
tell you in last yeah I know you went to
an all-black high school very nob lot of
black in my high school elementary was
mainly Oh a lament to elementary middle
school with all black a lot of a lot of
yeah and how many white Elementary for
the ratio of black to white cuz I mean
think of Aurora semi gold white 70/30
oh wow maybe 6040 any mix in a few
Mexicans a few Chinese kid your token
Chinese kid or some you had a very
ethnic upbringing yes very very urban
upbringing a very black sports were
important yeah
that's why fashion was important so you
got like a media Kenseth was import
oh yeah fashion you grew up competing
against primarily black athletes yeah
all the time
interesting alright well speaking of
urban I will be in Sacramento
next Thursday Friday I'm sorry next
Friday Saturday punchline get your
tickets now Friday Saturday those
tickets are almost sold out Friday
Saturday two shows Friday to show
Saturday and then after that I'm in New
York City Gotham comedy club New York
City November 30th through December
first and then I'm in New Mexico I think
it's Santa Fe New Mexico Casino out
there that is December 7th and 8th and
then the grand old hog Oso and both
shows are almost sold out biggest
theater I've ever done Spreckels theater
San Diego January 19th shooting my
one-hour special for a Showtime yes get
your tickets now f @k calm also as you
guys listen this this post today
tomorrow is the last day they're almost
sold out there are 30 spots left for the
pre-order of the fire in the kid collab
we did with Lisa fight I was rocking the
jacket earlier it comes with the jacket
the special hand-stitched
[ __ ] if you're finally kid fan has
everything everything from the the
patches the the freaking gay owl patch
the certified dick diver 10% gay the
cowboy is so so well done and it's
pre-ordered they're almost
sold out so with this you get an abbot
kinney Fight Club vintage gym bag you
get the vintage sweats you know roots
fight makes the softest sweats in the
world and then you get the dope ass coat
yeah so it's a high price point and it's
because it's all handmade very limited
edition and it's almost sold out there I
think something like 25 spots left and
then we are all sold out but tomorrow is
the last day to place the order so you
get them yet in January there you go
keep at kake.com and get them there
roots of fight comm get them there yep
but either way Sacramento I will see you
next week Brian buddy I'm gonna be
hitting the road in February and I'll
talk about that when the time is right
yeah Stan I was just saying did you want
to say all right so look forward to that
dude this is fine kid with frank grillo
and a surprise visit from Theo the Rat
King Vaughan we're out